Nvidia didn't sample the 5060, so we
bought one while we were in
Taiwan.
Taiwan Nvidia
[Music]
GPU.
Okay. In fact, even crisis works on
here. Okay, so anybody who's a GeForce
gamer, there no GeForce gamer in the
room. Fortunately, they were in abundant
supply in the stores, which told us that
very few people were buying them. Today,
we're reviewing the RTX 5060. We bought
one in Taiwan and we bought one on
Newegg. Between them, we paid $330 for
the Newegg one, $360 for the one from
Taiwan. So, we're ignoring MSRP and
we're using the price we actually paid
for purposes of this review. This is a
post-launch review by Nvidia's Choice,
which means we can use real price data
rather than what largely turns out to be
fake MSRPs anyway. And after what we
said recently about our beliefs about
Nvidia trying to control the narrative
for media, we're probably going to be
buying a lot more Nvidia GPUs uh for the
future. But that's okay because it'll
probably make Jensen happy. Nothing
gives me more joy than when you buy
everything from Nvidia.
I just want you guys to know
that.
But it gives me tremendous joy if you
just buy something from Nvidia. And
that's all I want in life. I just want
poor Jensen to be happy as quickly as
possible. The 5060 is about the same as
a 3070. The 5060 Ti 16 GB we tested in
these charts is typically between 15 and
25% better than the 5060 across 1080p,
1440p, and 4K. against the 4060 Ti.
Typically, the 5060 is either slightly
worse or slightly better. They're
largely about the same with a swing of
about 5% one way or the other. The 5060
is between 6% and 27% better than the
4060 depending on the game tested and
the resolution. Commonly about 20%, the
5060 is also about 34% to 49% better
than the 3060 from 2021. But VRAM is the
problem. 8 gigabytes becomes limiting at
times and will increasingly become a
limiter. There are a couple games where
Intel's B580 performs at about the level
of the new RTX 5060. Intel still has a
lot of ground to gain though, so it's
not fully there yet to take the market
share, but it's getting closer. AMD's
RX960 XT will launch soon, so we'll have
a review of that one within days. And if
you're watching this right before that
launch, just wait. I just you'll have
the data soon. And it appears like the
5060 is not going anywhere. There are
plenty of options to get one if you
still want a day or two. In this review,
we're going to have data going back to
the GTX 1060 6 GB from
2016, which means we have had a 33%
increase in VRAM in almost 10 years. So,
that's good. That's that's great. Let's
get into this quick review. Before that,
this video is brought to you by
Thermalite and the Frozen Prism 360
liquid cooler. Thermal Wright's frozen
prism is one of the most affordable
liquid coolers on the market and is able
to achieve competitive results with a
high cold plate convexity that applies
pressure essentially to the silicon area
based on our testing. This works on both
AMD and Intel. We previously benchmarked
the frozen prism and found that it's
overall competitive for its price point.
The cooler comes in a few color
variations. It has a blackout option and
an RGB option, and it's the cheapest
liquid cooler we've tested anytime
recently that still hits performance
markers. Learn more at the link in the
description below. Quick overview on the
specs. The 5060 remains readily
available online even now. It ranges
from $300 to $360 commonly, but as of
filming this, we are seeing options at
$300 and $320 again because probably
they're preempting the 960 XT launch.
Those were out of stock when we bought
ours. The RTX 5060 has 8 GB of GDDDR7
memory on an anemic 128bit bus. It has
3,840 CUDA cores, theoretically 48
rocks, but who the [__] knows if they're
actually there. And it uses GB 206 for
this core. It's also on a PCIe 5.0 by8
interface. So, it's populating half of
the available lanes. And in fact, on
this model, which is called the Gigabyte
Eagle OC, which is not really that OC,
it's using a halflength slot. So, in the
very least, for as many downsides as
cutting the length count in half can
have for older systems when socketing
this into something as an upgrade from
years and years ago, the benefit is it's
at least not using a full-length slot.
This is about as cut down a model as
Nvidia could have possibly made while
still calling it RTX. In our previous
video about Nvidia's shrinkflation, we
made this chart showing how Nvidia's
modern RTX 4060 is similar to the GTX
750 and Guda Core present relative to
the larger configuration. And in fact,
its RTX 5070 was similar to an RTX 3050
by this metric. If we were to add the
5060 to this chart, it'd be at 15.6% of
the full GB 202 config and 17.6% of the
5090. So, this card is hardly deserving
of the GeForce branding, especially
GeForce RTX. But, as Jensen Juan said,
there no GeForce gamer in the room.
That's right. Like vampires, they've
sucked the lifeblood out of PC gaming
and have successfully damaged the gaming
industry, but the core remains the
anti-consumer behavior, which just kind
of brings everyone down. So, anyway, on
that positive note, let's benchmark this
video card. Starfield is up now. At
1080p, the RTX 5060 ran at 66 FPS
average and improved upon the 3060 Ti by
an impressive world rending
3.1%. This is the improvement we came
here for. This is why we buy GPUs. In
just five short years, and one dead
add-in board partner later, the EVGA
3060Ti FTW3 has finally been unseated by
a new 60class card. Wow, that's
exciting. Even more excitingly, the 5060
improves upon the 4060 by 4.1 FPS
average. That's such a big improvement
that it's almost noticeable. This 6.6%
uplift isn't just something that you can
get with any technology. You have to
actively try to produce this little of
an improvement. If only we ran all of
this through an arbitrary frame
multiplier, it'd look impressive.
Against the 6T700 XT, uplift is only
13%. Intel is still bested by Nvidia. So
the B580 here running at 51 FPS average
yielded a 29% advantage to the 5060.
However, the ARC GPUs have had issues
with frame time pacing in this game.
That significantly hurt their viability
beyond what the average FPS shows. And
you can see that in the 1% and.1% lows.
Below that, the 3060 ran at 49 FPS
average for a 34% uplift to the 5060,
with the 2060 yielding a 73%
improvement. At 1440p, the 5060 ran at
52 FPS average and slightly trailed the
3070. The lead over prior generations
lines up like this. The 4060's 47 FPS
average is indistinguishable at a human
level, though technically the 5060 is 9%
better in average frame rate. The same
is true against the 6700 XT. Intel's
B580 is down at 41 FPS average and gives
the 5060 an advantage of 27%, but again
with the frame time pacing issues. The
3060's 38 FPS average establishes a 37%
improvement to the 5060 when spanning
multiple generations with the B570 and
A70 both in a similar spot for the
average. Upgrading from an RTX 2060 in
this exact test would produce a 72%
improvement in average frame rate. But
unfortunately for the 5060, the 4060 Ti
and 3070 are both superior, and the 3060
Ti is functionally identical in
performance to the new 5060, which is
just sad. The RTX 3060Ti is almost too
good by today's standards. Despite
initial mixed reviews years ago, if only
we knew how much worse it would get. It
caused issues for the 4060 Ti at launch,
and now it's causing issues for the
5060. 4K has fewer results because none
of it really matters anyway. The RTX
5060 ran at 33 FPS average in this test.
What we care about is the relative
comparison. The 5060 is beaten by the
3070Ti by 17%, which will probably be a
relevant number in a day or two. Not
going to say why, but it just feels like
it. The 5060Ti is just past that marker
at 41 FPS average, leading the 5060 by
25%. The 5070 is next in the hierarchy,
up at 65% improvement. The 9070 runs at
about the level of a 4070Ti, but we'll
see where the 9060 XT falls soon. In
Dragon Sagma 2 at 1440p, the RTX 5060
ran at 57 FPS average with lows at 45 to
47. Proportionally, these are well
spaced lows, indicating good frame
pacing. The 5060's average equates to
the 4060Ti 16 GB from last generation,
but with half of the VRAM. The RTX
5060Ti outperforms the 5060 by 22% here.
That's the 16 GB model, the Ti. The 9060
XT would be interesting if we were
allowed to show it already, but we might
not have tested it yet. And if we had,
we couldn't show it. We can show the
9070 though, and that's at 106 FPS
average with its own consistent frame
pacing. The lead over the 5060 is 86%.
Pricing is also significantly higher,
though. The two generation old 6T700 XT
roughly equates the 5060 as does the
3070 from a few generations back. We're
seeing sold eBay listings for around
$270 to $320 for the 3070, putting it in
the same price class as a new 5060. The
3060 Ti ran at 53 FPS average, meaning
it achieved 93% of the performance of
the 5060. The 3060Ti was originally
around $400 MSRP and today can be found
in sold eBay listings for $150 to $260
with several listings selling around
$230. Intel's Arc B580 ran at 44 FPS
average in this test, allowing the 5060
a lead of 30%. MSRP is $250 and the
cards were commonly in the 400s for a
while, but we're seeing regular listings
now at $300 new at price par in this
game specifically. That makes the 5060 a
better buy than the B580. But Intel is
at least entering the conversation and
it is competitive in some of the other
games. Against the last generation 4060,
the 5060 leads by 27% at 57 FPS to 45
FPS average. Against the 3060 from 2021,
the improvement is 45%. It's not great
for 4 years versus the 2060 from 2019.
Uplift is 87%. AMD's 9060 XT is what we
really need to study in a day or so,
though. At 1080p, the RTX 5060 ran at 76
FPS average and held lows at 60 to 62
FPS. The 3070 again roughly equates the
5060 with the 3060Ti only marginally
behind at 68 FPS average. The 6T700 XT
ties the 3060 Ti with the 5060 about 12%
better than both. Generationally, the
5060 improves on the 4060 by 23%, the
3060 by 48%, the 2060 by 91%, and the
1060 by
237%. Although the GTX 1060, this one
specifically, had a variant at 6 GB. So,
somehow we've only improved on that by
33% capacity. Above the 5060, we have
the 4060 Ti at a couple FPS ahead, which
is just embarrassing for the 5060. As
with the 9060, uh, moving on, the 5060
Ti leads the 5060 by 22% with the 5070
leading by 65% and 9070 by 75%. Price on
all of these is higher. These latter two
are significantly more expensive, of
course, so that lead makes sense. Final
Fantasy 14 Dawn Trail is up now, first
at 4K. This particular set of tests is a
weaker showing for the AMD RX90 series.
As we've shown in the 9070 XT and 9070
reviews, Nvidia is mostly competing
against itself here. The RTX 5060 ran at
47 FPS average when at 4K, landing it
below the Intel B580. That's great news
for Intel considering this is only their
second generation. Lows are the same
between them, meaning frame time pacing
is the same. Another victory for Intel
considering how new it is here. The 5060
Ti leads the 5060 by a poultry 16% with
the 4070 28% ahead and the 9070 34%
ahead. Again, the 9070 series has not
done well in Final Fantasy 14 in this
testing and that shows here. The other
direction, the 5060's 47 FPS average
leads the 460Ti by just 5 FPS with the
6700 XT just behind that. For reference,
sold 6700 XT 12 gigabyte listings have
the card between 200 and $320 commonly
in the US. The A770 is just below that,
giving the 5060 just a 16% lead.
Generationally, the 5060 leads the 4060
by 28%, the 3060 by 41%, the 2060 by
64%, and the 1060 by 191%. 1440p has the
5060 again tied with Intel's B580 again
in an embarrassing showing for Nvidia.
If Intel keeps at it, the company may
have a real chance at disruption. The
hard part for Intel will be maintaining
competitive prices while often using
larger dies to be competitive. The
3060Ti leads the 5060 and another
embarrassment for Nvidia at 3% ahead of
the 5060. The 3070 and 7700 XT are next
in line above, followed by the 5060 Ti
16 GB at 19% ahead. The gap over the
5060 increases at 1440p versus 4K based
on these numbers. Generationally, the
5060 uplift over the 4060 Ti is just 4%
or 21% over the 4060, 39% over the 3060,
56% over the 2060, and 163% over the
1060. All of these numbers are down
versus the improvement at 4K. Resident
Evil 4 at 4K has the RTX 5060 at 46 FPS
average. Again, basically tying the RTX
3070. But there's something worse this
time. The A770 also ties the 5060 with
the B580 just behind it. The RTX 5060Ti
leads the 5060 by 22% here. And we'll
have to see if the 9060 XT falls
anywhere near this area, just vaguely at
all, but we don't know yet, obviously.
For now, the 9070 is 96% ahead at a much
higher base price. Against older parts,
the 5060's 46 FPS average has it
basically tied with the 4060 Ti and only
7% ahead of the 3060 Ti. The B570 sits
down here too with the 4060 down at 35
FPS average to give the 5060 a lead of
34%. Improvement on the 3060 is 55% with
the uplift on the 2060 at 92%. At 1440p,
the RTX 5060 ran at 91 FPS average and
kept frame time pacing consistent. Not
in a remarkable way, but a predictable
one. Most of the GPUs tested in this
game farewell for frame time pacing, and
the 5060 is among them. The 4060 Ti had
a result functionally equal to the 5060
with the 6T700 XT slightly ahead of both
and in all three metrics. The 3070Ti is
next with the 5060 Ti at 112 FPS average
and ahead of the 5060 by 24%. Below the
5060, the A770 and B580 both encroach on
its rank at about 85 FPS average.
Unfortunately for Intel though, frame
times are inconsistent on these cards as
shown in the low variability for the
B580 as compared to the A770 and the
5060. ARC still has ground to gain here.
It's just inconsistent in general right
now. Versus lowered down GPUs, the 5060
improves upon the 3060 TiFTW3 by 10%,
the B570 by 24%, the 6600 XT by 28%,
4060 by 31%, and the 2060 by 94%.
Blackmmith who call is up next, which is
a title that does particularly well with
Nvidia devices and disproportionately so
in ray tracing later. Predictably 4K is
unplayable on the RTX 5060. The 5060
ends up at 25 FPS average. From a
relative standpoint, the 5060 Ti has a
23% higher average frame rate, which is
consistent with other tests. The 5070 is
59% better here and approaching
playability, but isn't there yet. The
9070 is around the same level as the
5070, including in 1% and.1% lows. But
let's move on to something more
realistic. 1440p, the 5060 runs at 46
FPS average with frame time pacing
consistent, not different from most
other cards in this test with the
exception of Intel. The 5060 is about
tied with the 3070 and 7700 XT.
Realistically, the 4060Ti 16 GB is also
at about the same performance as the
5060 here, but with way more VRAM. The
3060Ti's 42 FPS average means that the
5060 has improved upon it by just 9%.
Generationally, the 5060 is 25% ahead of
the 4060, 47% ahead of the 3060, and 84%
ahead of the 2060. At 1080p, the 5060
held a playable 66 FPS average with lows
representing consistent frame times. The
7700 XT, 4060 Ti, 16 GB, and 3070 are
all indistinguishable in experience for
the player. The 3070Ti isn't much
different either. The 5060 ends up
better than the 3060 Ti by only 13.5%.
It improves on the 4060 by 21% and
Intel's B580 by 44%. Dynite 2 rasterized
is up next at 4K. The 5060 ran at just
32 FPS average and tied the 2080 Ti from
2018. The 5060 Ti leads the 5060 by 21%.
And we need to move down resolution to
see other cards. 1440p adds a lot of
devices to the chart. The 5060 is now at
62 FPS average, performing about the
same as the 6T700 XT. And again,
disappointingly for Nvidia, the 3060 Ti,
this was also one of the games where the
3060Ti embarrasses the 4060Ti
previously. So, at least we see that
trend continuing for one last
generation. Hopefully, they could always
do another one, I guess. Even Intel's
B580 outperforms the 5060 this time in
both the average frame rate and the
lows. The 5060Ti outperforms the 5060 by
20% here against the 4060 Ti. The 5060
is roughly equivalent again with the
uplift over the 4060 at 26% followed by
the 3060 at 52% improved to the 5060.
Cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty is up
now. The last one for rasterization here
at 4K and rasterize the 5060 ran at 24.4
FPS average. The only usefulness here is
for relative comparison. That's the same
as the 3070 and slightly behind the
3070Ti. The 5060Ti is 28% ahead in
average frame rate here with the 7800 XT
ahead of that. At 1440p, the 5060 hits
55 FPS average in this test. That has it
right between the 3070 Ti and the 3070
and experientially the same. The 5060Ti
is better in average frame rate by 26%
coming down from the 4K lead. At 1080p,
the 5060 moves up to 89 FPS average and
remains sandwiched by the 3070 and 3070
Ti. We haven't rerun the 4060 through
this test lately, but the 9060 XT will
definitely be an interesting data point
to see. Moving on to rateracing testing
now. In Blackmith at 4K with upscaling,
the RTX 5060 ran at 24 FPS average and
roughly tied the 9070, which performs
awfully in the specific game with RT.
And it's also near the 3070 Ti. This is
unplayable and limited VRAM will get the
best of it as play time extends as well.
So, let's move on. 1440p with upscaling,
the RTX 5060 ran at 45 FPS average and
again roughly tied the 9070, which isn't
good for the 9070. This game continues
to be an impossible challenge for AMD.
The 5060 Ti leads the 5060 by 20% here.
Similar to what we saw in rasterized
scenario at 1080p with upscaling, the
5060 now runs at 64 FPS average and is
about equal to the 4060Ti 16 gigabyte
and to the 3080. This is the original 10
GB model. The 4060 also appears on this
chart at 52 FPS average with the 5060
ahead by 23%. The 3060Ti's 48 FPS
average means the 5060 improves on the
Ampier card by 34%. or 77% ahead of the
3060's 36 FPS average. The B580 isn't
particularly competitive here either,
down at 34 FPS average and around the
2070. Dragon Stoma 2 with ray tracing
and tested at 4K has the 5060 at just 30
FPS average, which we all know humans
definitely can't see faster than. That's
the limit. That's as much as we can do.
It's 30 FPS. And so this card's
basically perfect, just like Jensen
said. Does that make any
sense? And it's
perfect. It's completely perfect. It
guessed it perfectly. The 5060 Ti leads
the 5060 by 18% here, but again, we
can't see those frames anyway, so who
cares? Let's move on to 1440p for more
results we can't see. At 1440p with rate
tracing, the RTX 5060's 50 FPS average
means you'd be able to run SLI with two
eyeballs to see that frame rate. that
ties it with the 4060 Ti 16 gigabyte and
with the 3070. The 7700 XT seems like a
particularly useful landmark for future
benchmarks and reviews for reasons we
can't particularly explain right now. It
just kind of came to us in a vision. And
as for the generational improvement, the
5060 posts a 27% improvement over the
4060, which was previously bested by the
3060 Ti, and a 47% improvement over the
3060 non Ti. 1080p brings the 5060 up to
67 FPS average when tested with ray
tracing. This has its performance
experientially the same as the results
for the 4060 Ti and the 3070. With the
3060Ti not that different in experience
at 60 fps average, the 6700 XT is in the
same boat as the 3060 Ti here. And over
last gen, the 5060 improves by 23% by
name only. That's ignoring Nvidia's name
games it plays where a 5060 is basically
like a modern 30 or 50 class card at
best. Dynite 2 with ray tracing and at
1440p upscaled is next. In this one, the
5060 ran at 49 FPS average with the 5060
Ti ahead by 22%. AMD does comparatively
better in this one versus its Blackmith
performance earlier, but we need to go
down to 1080p for more cards. At 1080p
upscaled, the 5060 72 FPS average has
about the same as the 4060Ti 16
gigabyte, but the 4060 Ti had superior
0.1% lows in this set of test passes.
The 5060 is about 9 to 10% better than
the B580 and the 3060Ti. So, Intel is
doing better here than in some other
benchmarks. Its lows are also more
consistent than some of its previous
performances. against the 4060. The 5060
is 25% improved or 56% improved over the
3060. Andy's direct competitor will be
on our chart within days, so we'll check
back for that. But for now, the 7800 XT
seems like maybe a reasonable comparison
and outperforms the 5060 by 13%.
Resident Evil 4 at 4K is up now, this
time ray traced and with upscaling. The
5060 ran at 55 FPS average, again,
roughly tying it with a 3070 and 6700
XT. The 5060Ti is again around 22%
better than the 5060 in average FPS here
with lows improved proportionally.
Intel's B580 remains more competitive
than Nvidia probably wants it to be, but
it still has some ground to gain to
directly compete with Nvidia when
assuming price parody. And this is all
just looking at one chart anyway. It's
getting there though. AMD's direct
competitor will be on the charts soon
enough. At 1440p with upscaling and RT,
the RTX 5060's 92 FPS average has it
about equal to the 460Ti 16 GB and
slightly ahead of the 3070 and 6700 XT.
The 560Ti leads by 22%. Again, Intel's
B580 is still back far enough that
Nvidia has some breathing room as long
as Intel doesn't make a big generational
gain with Celestial. But that's a huge
assumption to make. Nvidia has been at
this a long time. and they're very
competitive. Against older hardware, the
5060 improves upon the 3060 Ti's 81 FPS
average by a little over 10 FPS with the
improvement on the 4060 at about 30%. As
for power consumption and efficiency
data, we have that, but we're going to
just put that in the 960 XT review so we
have something to compare it to. So,
check back for the power data and for
power efficiency. And if you're watching
this video much later after it's
published, it would be in the RX960 XT
review that you can find on the channel.
So, 960 XT reviews go up tomorrow. No,
you should not buy this right now. Wait
for the 960 XT review. There is no
shortage of supply of these, it appears.
And if there is, then [__] it anyway.
But the 960 XT when that comes out,
we'll have that review. You'll be able
to analyze the full market at this price
spectrum at that point. And uh that's
got an 8 gigabyte and a 16 gigabyte
model. Also, the 8 GB model will have
all the same complaints, which are that
within years, you're going to run into
limitations in at least some scenarios.
And, you know, it's it's this is it's
getting ridiculous. This is like it's
beyond product segmentation at this
point. And again, my firm belief is that
Nvidia is damaging the PC gaming hobby
and PC building. Uh, and we explained
that in the hardware and box discussion
we had on their channel. So, um, anyway,
as for this specific card, we'll talk
more about its value in the 960 XT
review. Nvidia is doing a lot of shady
[__] right now. Uh, it is acting in what
we believe to be an anti-consumer way.
It's doing underhanded things, we think,
with its partners, both uh, industry
partners and media. And uh yeah, we we
just don't I mean like Jensen said, you
know, when you're CEO, you have many
children, but it's not because we don't
love GeForce, but coming down to the
hardware itself, we'll have those
numbers for you in tomorrow's video. So
anyway, that's it for this one. Check
back on the channel tomorrow because
that's what's really going to matter. Go
to store.gamersac.net to support us
directly because I mean, if they don't
send us cards, it's fine. We'll just buy
them in multiple locations if I have to.
And uh you can go to patreon.com/gamers
nexus to help us out there as well.